Kunst trifft auf industriedenkmal die ehemalige eisenhütten in völklingen
ist eine ideale kulisse für den 8 allein auf der außenanlage haben 20 künstler ihre werke installiert
diesen schornstein hat sich der künstler mambo ausgesucht er lebt in los angeles und hat schon in den 1980 er jahren street art gemacht
heute ist er ein etablierter künstler
er arbeitet schon lange nicht mehr mit der spraydose
sondern mit dem pinsel
Die adrenalinausschüttung beim illegalen malen kann süchtig machen das war wie eine dose
jetzt fokussiere ich mich mehr auf den stil den ausdruck und mein eigenes vokabular
das ist eine andere arbeit es ist eine studioarbeit aber ich fühle mich mehr als künstler ich muss nichts illegales wir machen
Gleich mehrere werke wurden von den berliner künstlern mental gassi angebracht sie haben autoren gittern und silos menschen
porträtiert die heute in der völklinger hütte arbeiten
In ihrem berliner studio werden die fotos im riesenformat
ausgedruckt die künstler arbeiten schon seit 20 jahren in den straßen verschiedener städte weltweit häufig natürlich ohne erlaubnis
nun sind sie bei der erben art biennale eingeladen das gelände zu bespielen wir suchen immer nach
objekten oder architektouren die dreidimensional sind oder zumindest irgendwie eine tiefe haben oder irgendwie in den raum rein gehen
damit wir
nicht nur ein planes bild ein kleines porträt abbilden können sondern eben eigentlich eine foto skulptur erschaffen können
eine der porträtierten ist hendrik kerstens
Abgelichtet das wohl von allen seiten oben unten und musste übelste grimassen schneiden dann wurde entschieden super den nehmen wir
und ja das hatte ich mich dann hier wieder hin da diese art von fotografie doch ziemlich
mörderisch ist wasseroberflächen haut und so weiter angeht sind die damen nicht weiters kritischer als unter einer aber ich glaube sie kann damit leben
auch der künstler martino aus frankreich klebt eine kunst er hat sich ein häuschen dass arbeiter früher für pausen genutzt haben
ausgesucht und deutsche plakate aus den
1970 er jahren zum thema arbeitssicherheit
künstlerisch bearbeitet
Ich arbeite mit kleinen bildern die ich durch ein faxgerät schicke damit sie stärker gepixelt sind
Dann male ich davon eine größere fassung am ende versehe ich die bilder mit knalligen signalfarben
In der gewaltigen kulisse der sogenannten müller halle dort wo früher die rohstoffe des eisenbergs gelagert wurden
sind rund 100 weitere werke der urban art aus 20 ländern zu sehen es ist straßenkunst die nun auf leinwand gelandet ist
Die abend ist die kunst die als street art von der straße kommt am anfang sind diese
künstlerinnen und künstler als besitzstörung
verhaftet und ins gefängnis gesperrt worden und irgendwann gab es dann den punkt wo diese künstler
aus dem straßenraum heraus auf bewegliche gründe
bilder skulpturen gefertigt haben das ist der beginn unserer art biennale
und seitdem zeigen wir diese kunst die sich da aufgemacht hat auch als neue kultur richtung
richtung museum
die erben art biennale in völklingen zeigt dass inzwischen viele ehemalige
straßenkünstler auf dem weg sind sich einen sicheren platz auf dem kunstmarkt zu ermahnen